when i started out in my first it job i
met a guy let's let's call him bob
bob knew
everything
if you wanted to know how our 30 year
old billing system worked you called bob
network down bob kick it you're running
again
where the stash of the good coffee was
kept
see bob
and then not one month into my
employment bob sent out a company-wide
email informing us of his imminent
retirement no joke this caused
management some major worries and bob
spent his last few weeks furiously
documenting everything he knew
this is an example of a lack of recorded
enterprise knowledge what we needed all
along was a proper
knowledge
management
system
now knowledge management helps to not
only
create organizational memory but also
aids operational efficiencies increased
collaboration and identification of
skill gaps let's take a look
so knowledge management is the process
of identifying organizing storing and
disseminating information within an
organization when knowledge is not
easily accessible it can be incredibly
costly to a business
so where should this knowledge be
harvested and stored well in something
called a k
m
s or knowledge management system
supported by
a knowledge
base
but
well what is
knowledge we can probably define it into
three types
tactic implicit and explicit so tactic
knowledge
is typically acquired through well
experience and it is intuitively
understood so for example leadership
skills or recognizing facial expressions
a tactic knowledge is difficult to
codify and it's difficult to write down
there's also
implicit
knowledge
and impressive knowledge is kind of the
the know-how knowledge that has not been
written down or recorded yet but this is
the stuff that was that was in bob's
head
while this type of knowledge may not be
initially obvious it can be captured
with the right tools and with the right
processes and unlike tactic knowledge
implicit knowledge can usually be
codified and then finally there's
explicit
knowledge
information that is captured within
various document types such as manuals
and reports and guides and you'll find
explicit knowledge in databases white
papers and case studies
the goal of knowledge management is to
make this valuable enterprise knowledge
accessible to anyone who needs it and
when they need it in order to achieve
this businesses need to implement a
system for capturing storing and
disseminating information through the
company
an effective knowledge management system
typically goes through three main stages
so let's take a look at those
so knowledge
[Music]
and then stage one
is really the knowledge
creation
so knowledge creation is where
organizations identify and document any
existing or new knowledge that they want
to circulate across the company figure
out what it is we need to store
speaking of that stage two is knowledge
storage
and this is the stage that describes
where an its system is used to host
organizational knowledge for
distribution
information may need to be formatted in
a particular way to meet the
requirements of that repository
and then number three we have knowledge
sharing
this is the final stage in which
processes to share the knowledge are
communicated broadly across the
organization
so what knowledge management tools do we
have
at our disposal
well there's there's a whole bunch we'll
just cover a few of them and the first
of those is a content management system
or a cms
this is an application which manages web
content where end users can edit and
publish content and content here could
be document like you know an faq or it
could be some other form of media like a
piece of audio or or a video
that cms could be hosted on a public
website if this is intended for customer
consumption or it can be hosted on an
intranet for internal use
document management systems or dms
go beyond the web to act as a
centralized storage system for digital
documents such as pdfs images and word
processing files a great place to store
how-to guides or lessons learned
documents
and while cms and dms systems are
typically curated
a data
warehouse
is something that aggregates data from
different data sources into a single
central consistent data store often
through automated collation
a data warehouse can support data
analysis data mining artificial
intelligence and machine learning
data is extracted from these
repositories so that companies can
derive insights to make data-driven
decisions
now we've already talked about some
benefits of knowledge management
specifically maintaining enterprise
knowledge but there are many reasons to
embrace a knowledge management strategy
like for example identification of
skill
gaps
when teams create relevant documentation
around implicit or around tactic
knowledge or consolidate explicit
knowledge it can highlight gaps in core
competencies across teams great
information to use when building a
training plan or figuring out hiring new
resources
now knowledge management can also aid in
data
security
and in this case knowledge management
systems enable organizations to
customize permissions control or
viewership control and the level of
document security to ensure that
information is shared only in the
correct channels or with selected
individuals
and if employees know that a knowledge
management system is a go-to place to
find relevant information
this will also lead to operational
efficiencies from faster decision making
and improved productivity
knowledge management systems can be
created by skilled employees and
harvested through natural language
processing of existing document sources
and when employees are armed with the
right tools and strategies knowledge
management practices make it easier to
onboard new employees assist a more
productive workforce who know where to
look for the answers and enable customer
self service support portals
because well without one we're exposed
to the risk of losing institutional
knowledge when employees are no longer
around for us to ask
and
look i know this is a long shot but bob
if you are watching
just where did you hide away the good
coffee pods
thanks for watching and please consider
to like and subscribe to our channel
also in the comments let us know about
other tech topics you'd like us to cover
so we can continue to bring you content
that's relevant to you
like well some of these videos here
you